[Music]
this week the biden white house is
hitting the road
selling their covid relief plan and the
benefits for americans
part of the plan helps with local
vaccine rollouts and today vice
president harris and the second
gentleman
douglas emhoff went to las vegas and
visited a vaccine clinic
the plan also helped schools keep kids
in the classroom
safely and so there was the first lady
visiting a school
in new jersey meanwhile at the white
house president biden celebrated the
progress
and the hope he also warned the nation
that there is still more to be done
help is here and hope is here
in real and tangible ways we're just
days away from 100 million shots
and millions in the arms of millions of
americans
that's the way that's the way on the way
to get every single american access
the vaccine 100 million checks
going into the pockets and or direct
deposits going into the pockets of
americans
on the way to a million more millions of
more americans
that's real progress we have a lot more
to do
we have to prove to the american people
that their government can deliver for
them
and do it without waste or fraud
joining me now is white house press
secretary jen sake thank you so much for
being here
tonight hi there it's great to be here
the president spoke today and we heard
him just there saying it's so important
to prove to the american people
that their government can actually
deliver for them and do it without waste
or fraud
how does the biden administration go
about getting that done
well first we're going to focus on the
substance and the policy and
how this big package the president
signed into law last week helps
the american people so you mentioned the
vice president who's out today in las
vegas with her husband
visiting a vaccine clinic tomorrow the
president is headed to philadelphia
and he's going to be visiting some small
businesses and we are really trying
really to meet people where they are
and talk about the benefits from this
package how it's going to help them in
their everyday lives
and he's also appointed somebody to
oversee gene sperling who has a lot of
experience in government
who's going to oversee a lot of the
implementation here to make sure exactly
as you touched on there's no waste
there's no fraud there's no abuse
and that these this this relief is
getting out directly the american people
is there any strategy behind where he is
going i've obviously noted
uh he's going to do a joint event in
atlanta georgia
and you know there are most of these
places are either battleground states or
places where there are current political
controversies
uh georgia namely in terms of voter
suppression so
is it the strategy of the biden white
house to go to places
you know where the political uh terrain
is
is pretty hot because it seems it seems
from my vantage point curious the
strategy
sure i mean a big part of why he's going
to georgia i mean one we're watching
what's happening there very closely and
obviously the
the the efforts to suppress voters and
to make it more difficult for people to
vote is something that's of huge concern
to the president and the entire
administration
but he's going to georgia because he
campaigned uh for
uh the new the two newest members of the
senate uh in georgia in december
with the promise of making sure that
1400 checks were delivered
uh to the american people and we we're
now delivering on that promise so
that's a big part of why he's going back
to georgia obviously it also helped him
win the presidency
but that's going to be a big part of his
message we're also going to head to some
red states or lena we'll head to some
blue blue states as well so this is just
what the plan is for this week
you said today that the biden white
house would welcome donald trump
encouraging people to get the vaccine
as you we noted in the last block he got
it in private and didn't tell anybody
for many months
um have you guys reached out to the
former president on this issue would you
be willing to collaborate with him on
something if it meant that he was going
to encourage those republican men out
there to get this vaccine
you know we we certainly wouldn't turn
it down if he went out there as i said
earlier
today but also most all past presidents
aside from him have gone out there and
shown
made the clear case that this vaccine
these vaccines are effective
that they're going to save lives and
they didn't require engraved invitations
so i wouldn't say we're going to spend a
lot of time reaching out to him we also
know from a lot of data and polling that
the most effective messengers are
actually not political figures
they are local doctors they are civic
leaders and this doesn't surprise you at
all i'm sure
there are people in communities who are
trusted so right now we're really
focused on
increasing supply because access is a
big issue and a big challenge
we're going to get to the point in a
month or a little more where p
there's more people who who won't take
the vaccine and more supply that we have
you know that will be more of the issue
then so right now we're focused on
access supply
but we're really going to start to work
on empowering those doctors those local
officials
folks who are really trusted in their
community that works with both democrats
republicans people who aren't even
engaged in politics
what's the strategy of the
administration if donald trump doesn't
uh help if he's not willing to go on uh
go out there and
encourage his supporters to get the
vaccine what's the plan to encourage
that republican base to get the vaccine
because we all
need them to get it we all american
americans need them to get it
you're absolutely right i mean first of
all donald trump former president trump
is not the only
republican who is looked to as a leader
there are a lot of members of congress
who certainly could be more leaders
in getting the vaccine making clear
about the effectiveness the efficacy of
it
on the republican side of the aisle so
we'll be encouraging that but
you know again it is what you've seen
through data and polling that
the most trusted sources of information
on the vaccine
on the effectiveness on the vaccine on
the safety of the vaccine
our doctors local civic leaders and
we're really going to focus our efforts
on empowering them
engaging them and you know starting to
to get them out into local communities
some of that will be done directly by us
some of it will be done by groups we're
partnering with but we we are very eyes
wide open to the fact that we are not
going to be the white house the biden
white house
the right uh the right voice for every
single person and certainly not trump
supporters so
we're trying to be creative about who
we're working with but it's mostly local
officials
doctors medical experts who we have seen
are the most effective
yeah that makes a lot of sense uh
turning uh to the issue of immigration
it's a big challenge right now for the
administration
with what's going on at the southern
border some people have called it a
crisis
would you call it that i mean a record
number of migrant children
are in us custody right now what does
the administration want people to know
about how you're dealing with the
situation
it's it's incredibly challenging it's
it's emotional i will say for many of us
as a mom you watch these kids and it's
really hard on this issue what our focus
is on
is taking action and putting in steps in
place
to make sure we're expediting we're
shorting the period of time where any of
these kids are in these border patrol
stations they're not made for children
we want to get them quickly into hhs run
facilities that have acts that where
kids can have access to educational
resources to health and medical experts
to
even mental health counseling legal
counseling and then we want to get them
with families
with their families if possible
hopefully or with sponsor homes
and we're trying to look for creative
ways to even do that faster so
there's a lot of logistical steps we're
taking here we need more facilities that
are safe
and meet all those standards i outlined
we're trying to embed people earlier in
the process that can help people connect
with family members and with
with safe homes they can go to uh you
know and of course we're trying to
expedite it at the front end
because we just we don't the biggest
issue right now is the length of time
these kids are in these border patrol
facil
facilities yeah absolutely i mean i
think everyone agrees that
uh children should not be detained um
in in you know unsafe conditions uh on
the border no matter what so i i think
that
you know going back to the previous
administration they had specific
policies in place
which led to certain outcomes in terms
of the change in policy
what has the blind administration done
tangibly to change what the trump
administration was doing
regardless of whether or not uh either
is the cause
of this influx on the border right now
unaccompanied minors
but how do you see it as um in terms of
what was the the actual cause of this
well the biggest change is that we're
not sending kids back on the treacherous
journey we're not sending unaccompanied
children
back on that journey home where many of
them wouldn't make it they were being
picked up by gangs there were a lot of
issues and
that's what in our view the more humane
approach so that is having
that is a factor with the number of
people who are uh currently coming
across the border
i will say there's there's cyclical in
increases uh
there was one in 2018 2019 there was one
in 2014
with with migrants coming to the border
so we've seen um
versions of this before and what we're
really dealing with at this point is
that over the last four years not only
was it an inhumane approach
to this really challenging circumstance
at the border
but the whole system was dismantled you
know it wasn't prepared for an influx of
children or an influx of migrants and
we're taking a different substantive
policy approach but we're also trying to
rebuild a very very broken system
and it's just taking it's taking some
time but we're doing everything we can
to expedite it
one of the things that's uh right for
debate right now is what to do about the
filibuster
um because it's you know according to
some folks it's standing in the way of a
lot of progress in terms of immigration
reform
uh raising the minimum wage to 15 and
also voting rights which
uh hr one has been passed by the house
and senators joe manchin
and merkley have talked about going back
to the talking filibuster which is
you know mr smith goes to washington or
the stockhouse filibuster if you're a
westwick fan um yeah
so um does the president agree with
any modifications to the filibuster say
on specific types of legislation or
modifying it to go back to
the talking filibuster to make folks
stand up and and have to in public
uh talk you know read the dictionary uh
to block voting rights
much more tiring uh you know i think
this the president's uh
preference has been not to make changes
however
he's also watching all these proposals
come forward from a range of democrats
it's essentially a senate rule right
it's how the rules of the senate work
and so he's going to be watching what
they're doing engaging with them about
their interests and making changes and
he's happy to
hear them out on what they'd of course
like to do but you know that that's been
his long preference and we'll see what
they come up with and
just like any issues he's happy to hear
them out on their proposals
okay so last question um is more of a
personal one
so from my point of view being press
secretary seems really terrifying
um and obviously you know we've lived
through four years of
no it's there's a it's really different
um it's very different you have to be on
your toes you have to uh say things in
the moment
and if you make a mistake that sort of
has could have international
you know repercussions um reporters are
constantly looking for you to make
mess up make mistakes have you ever been
scared
do you have like a song that gets you
pumped up before you go out do you have
a mantra
how do you do it you know i sometimes i
just have to take some deep breaths i
have a little like
shimmy to get the nerves out i do a
superhero pose every now and then
just to get myself psyched up uh and you
know at the end of the day i just can't
take it personally
that's that's the thing um and so that's
what i try to do every day i will say
i'm pretty lucky because i
when i was at the state department we
had reporters in there from
the chinese government russian
government state-run media so it's
prepared me for all sorts of things in
there
but sure i get a little bit of nervous
there's a little bit nervous there's big
stakes here and i try to kind of shake
it out as much as i can
i like the shimmy idea shaking your body
out before you
you do it it really is helpful it is
thank you so much for being here tonight
and please thank you for saving me we'd
love to have you back thank you anytime
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching